so richard everyone knows uh who's a fan
of the stern show that you are a huge
fan of cole heat and cambria start at
the beginning tell me about the first
time you heard these guys really the
kind of the first
time that maybe i was on your radar was
when i talked about you
guys on the stern show when i was at one
of your shows i think of a summer of
maybe 2006 or 2007
and uh and i was such a huge fan i
didn't want to miss any songs and the
porta porta-potties were like a mile
away it was an outdoor show in new
jersey so i just peed in my pants so i
didn't have to miss any songs
and
and then and then my wife and i got we
met these people at the show that
offered to give us a ride back to new
york city and i had to admit to them
because i didn't want to sit in their
nice car with my pee pants i had to say
listen i peed my pants can do you have a
towel i can sit on and my wife was
mortified she was like why would you pee
your pants at a concert and i'd explain
to her i love every coheed and cambria
song i can't go to the bathroom and miss
a couple songs if the porta-potties are
a mile away then howard recommended i
wear a diaper and then from then on i
started wearing a diaper to you guys
shows and then that kind of became a
thing and fans like started going
richard are you wearing your diaper and
if i didn't show them my diaper
physically they get really mad or
like
at certain shows i would go to the
i would actually use the bathroom at
some shows if there's a bathroom close
by and i've had people yell at me
they're like you poser you know
you wearing a diaper yeah they would boo
me i think you're a trailblazer i think
this is a brilliant idea i feel like i'm
going to start wearing diapers you don't
have to miss anything
that's great
yeah you're a progressive forward
thinking dude oh thanks josh i
appreciate it yeah you know a lot of
bands you go see
and you're like oh you just want to play
the old stuff with you guys it's like i
want you to play all the stuff and
especially the new album the new album
is like it's a masterpiece i hope maybe
you do another never ender tour where
you play the new album in full because i
just like i listen to it 20 times a day
and you guys are one of those rare bands
where every album is better than the
last i love going to see you guys when
you're playing the new stuff and of
course i love the old stuff too but it's
great
that's the reason i wear the diaper
there's no songs i can go pee during
every song is great
oh that's so good that's so nice what a
tremendous compliment oh yeah we don't
even know what to say it's hard to
render me speechless but
it's what an unbelievable compliment
dude thank you so much